breathtaking
[Music]
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottle
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
[Music]
in the shadows of Iraqis lie many
secrets
it's the darkest of them all may remain
the end of House of treaties my father
didn't believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
come on
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we all know that
be simple
be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
you will never lose people
we gave them something to hope for let's
not hope
May thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign